[Music]
continuing with The Descent comps in
this video we'll cover off pieces 8 to
12. if you haven't already I'd highly
recommend checking out the first two
videos on these cons as I'll be
referring back to them from time to time
I'll leave a link to these in the
description
it's ambitious the surveillance
technology and capabilities are a clear
Advantage for both the NSA and the Black
Tusk any downsides honestly
I don't know how secure their network is
it would be very easy for them to cut
corners and have everything funnel into
a central repository without doing an
on-site appraisal of their servers and
security I would expect other users on
the same network could access your comms
and Intel that's very helpful I aim to
please we should speak more after this
personal or professional professional
what's your favorite geometric shape a
diamond interesting
you know you can tell a lot about a
person by their favorite shape what's
yours technically it's a plain curve
parabola
yeah that's
you're not what I expected
if you don't remember Matthias trig
Schneider featured in season 10 the
price of power
he was a mathematics Prodigy he would go
on to graduate from MIT with a masters
in electrical engineering at the age of
18 and would become the Department's
youngest associate professor
his theoretical work with perpetual
energy turbines caught the eye of the
defense department he was brought into
consult with diaper scientists on
several classified projects
Matthias currently working as a
Department of Defense consultant has
been asked by Natalia and Kelvin to
check out the new AI system that Ortiz
Robotics are proposing he raises
questions about the potential security
flaws flaws that clear and Alex are
already aware of but haven't disclosed
to Natalya or kelvin
matthias's professional conversation
with circle over must have worked out
because sometime after this he was
recruited into the Black Tusk ranks
why would I want that if they can walk
on two legs instead of four they could
be more agile and fit through tighter
spaces sure I can see a use case for
that
so we're approved
how much is this going to cost me not
much we could even tack this onto the r
d budget you've already approved
Claire's really excited about the
prospects
so this is to make your wife happy
you know what they say
happy wife happy life
no one who is really happy says that
just a short one here and not a huge
amount disclosed but it does show that
Ortiz robotics contract with the
Department of Defense extends past the
new AI system they've been working on
and that they've been involved with a
lot of other Tech too
I see the value for Cal and his teams
but I don't really see the value in an
AI Handler for my organization if your
operatives are left alone in the field
my operatives would never be left alone
in the field in a perfect world yes but
we do not live in a perfect world go on
if an operative is alone in the field
our AI can take over robotics automation
to maintain perimeter defenses and the
likelihood of a friendly fire casualties
next to zero how does the AI detect
friendlies Biometrics and personalized
ID the watches and the bricks they're a
bit bulky any chance of miniaturization
or combining both the receiver and the
interface not in this generation we are
working on combining the two pieces into
a single unit but it would require a
larger interface to house both
components and will be exponentially
more expensive expense is not an issue
for me I think we'll stick with a more
cost effective and tested methods
watches and Bricks
this one makes it seem like these
columns aren't being collected in order
I assumed the AI Handler piece was the
main function of this technology yet now
Natalia is saying she doesn't want this
part of it Natalia also brings up that
the tech is too bulky and would like it
reduced to a single unit or at least
made smaller this is something that
Kelvin discussed with Alex and Claire
previously and they agreed to make a
single unit that can control all three
strictly just for him
everyone in this conversation is aware
of this apart from Natalia so they
attempt to push the idea aside Saint
will be ridiculously expensive but of
course the cost isn't a concern for
Natalya and this is where Kelvin jumps
in and puts his foot down saying they
will be sticking to the watches in
bricks
accusing Natalia Sokolova nice to meet
you Miss okalova Cal says he wants us to
work together I think he's just trying
to use my budget to expand his little
experiment is your organization using
the ort's robotics Tech yes you're not
worried about the potential security
breaches with Isaac yes we are not using
Isaac we're using the system agnostic
from the AI are you sure that's what
Alex told me declare confirm it no if
you don't mind I'd like to do a security
protocol check on your version of their
systems I believe there may be a major
exploit that could be a matter of
National Security well I don't belong to
any one nation my Enterprise is global
then there is a potential exploit to
your Global Security everything is
locked on a biometric server if you can
access my system I may have a job for
you or I may need to re-evaluate whether
or not to eliminate Alex from my future
endeavors
I'm a little confused about this one now
it's pretty obvious from the very first
descent comms the Kelvin has brought
Natalia in on this AI project with Ortiz
robotics to use her purchasing power to
help reduce the overall cost to the
Department of Defense economies of scale
and all that
kelvin's budget is considerably smaller
than natalius as she has said plenty of
times money isn't an issue so what
Calvin has tried to do is to get as much
out of the steel as possible while still
having some sort of one-up on net
keeping him in a higher position of
power
but by introducing net to this NSA
analyst he is potentially exposing the
flaw in the system that will give him
the control over all three systems
back to the comps Calvin had with clear
and Alex Ortiz perhaps he wasn't aware
that this was the way he was going to be
given this coverage of all three systems
or maybe clear has a different way of
having him be able to tap into each
but right now it seems like kelvin's
plan of having one watch to rule them
all is potentially at risk here
also given that this exploit is about to
be opened up I wonder where Alex and
Claire are right now
obviously Natalya ended up using the
tick they created but there's been a
fair amount of time that has passed
since this was recorded what happened to
them
I hope you understand
if you're not interested in renewing my
contract
sure
I understand and that all the design
work that you have created during your
tenure here is now property of Ortiz
robotics you own everything you don't
want that sucks and is broken
goody for you we own all of the designs
so if elements of your designs are
repurposed and used in any other
application you have no intellectual
property ownership or claim to any
designs that you have worked on during
your time at Ortiz robotics okay this is
not exclusive to designs you've
submitted for review this includes
designs that you've developed in the
last six months on any Ortiz robotics
equipment or on its properties what do
you mean it's properties since you were
living in corporate housing anything you
created in the apartment is also
property of Ortiz Robotics are you
kidding me I wish I was you
really should have read your contract
thoroughly before signing it if you have
an issue with this you could avoid the
clause in section 9 or found off-campus
house with what you pay me off campus
would have meant West Virginia we was
your grave Mark in the future and look
forward to seeing what you do next thank
you for all your contributions to Ortiz
robotics
sure we're gonna need that watch back
I don't even know where you got one of
those oh this
this was a gift from Cal
pretty sure this belongs to me
as a reminder Vivian was from Coney
Island in Warlords of New York Vivian
Conley comes from a chemical engineering
background and was recruited by the
division both as a field agent and
Technology developer after the outbreak
Conley was activated as a first wave
agent her job was to secure the
quarantine Zone in Midtown Manhattan
when the jtf pulled out of the Zone
Conley was among the many other agents
who became trapped
after finding out that a family had
succumbed to the green poison along with
having to do whatever it took to survive
in the dark Zone she would eventually
become marked as Rogue
some time later cleaners were scouting
the duck soon they found calmly alive
trapped under some Rubble she would end
up joining the cleaners and after Joe
farrow's death Conley successfully
reorganized the cleaners and became
their leader
obviously this comms takes place long
before the event that played out on
Coney Island and Warlords of New York
this talks about how Vivian is being
released from Ortiz robotics by her
contract not being reviewed
essentially she is losing everything
she's worked on while in their
employment even things she worked on in
her spare time
not that this matters in the long run
but I wonder if this is anything to do
with the Ortiz set that is about to come
out in the year 5 season 2. she does
have a chemical engineering background
and would eventually become the leader
of the cleaners and the set has a heavy
focus on fire
however the end of this comms is
interesting Alex attempts to climb back
an Isaac watch that she is wearing on a
wrist but also questions why she has it
obviously the Strategic Homeland
division program has already been
started at this stage and she has
already been recruited
I found these ones a little lighter on
the content than the previous ones
however I think this certainly building
up towards something unfortunately I'm
not seeing anything new in these that I
haven't already talked or speculated
about in the previous two videos
Helen McManus is attempting to hold
control over Natalia Aaron Kina and what
he discovered and the hunters in the
place and all of this
but I feel as though it will make more
sense in the coming weeks
admittedly I'm a little behind on these
comms is real-life obligations have had
me miss a couple of weeks of descent but
I'll catch up it looks like for now that
the total number of descent coms has
stopped changing so there really isn't
too many left
anyway thank you very much for watching
and I'll catch you soon in the next one
extremist malice extreme remedial
[Music]
[Applause]